I'm going to admit to you I'm almost a
little bit starting to think about maybe
feeling kind of bad for the failed
former president Donald Trump
look at the people that are into
interviewing him lately look at the
sorts of appearances he's doing where he
can't even be bothered to put a camera
in front of his face he's quite
literally just phoning it in and even
with the friendliest interviewers just
making a complete and total fool of
himself low energy interviews where
Trump just tells a lot of the same lies
he's told for a while but you can tell
even his heart's not even really in the
lies and the themes are delusion and the
rewriting of History confusion in many
cases as well as weaponized narcissism
Trump appeared yesterday calling in of
course on real America's voice and it's
just bizarre that he's still trying to
get away with these same tired lies the
host is completely friendly and Trump
still can't figure out a way to seem
like a normal person here is Trump
weighing in on the investigation into
him Trump says they should drop the
investigation into what I did with all
those classified documents because
because of the 12 documents that were
left behind by Joe Biden somewhere that
his lawyers immediately found and
contacted the presidential the Nara
National Archives listen to this and you
of course have been facing this
situation with the special prosecutor
how does this change the equation with
what you've been doing with the justice
department to get this map and remember
the question is how does the Biden thing
change your situation the answer is not
at all
well I think it totally changes it I
mean he's again he's under this federal
act that's very tough and I'm gonna I I
was perfect under the presidential
records act we were negotiating with
Nara now you know Nara is a far left
group of people that's not true I don't
know if you know or if you've ever heard
they've red flagged essentially red flag
the Constitution of the United States
they said it's a dangerous document this
is what we're dealing with these are
people that uh you know look they have
some real difficulties so listen first
of all if you are accused of murder and
then someone else gets accused of murder
they don't stop investigating you they
investigate both of you and maybe of the
two people accused of murder one person
did the thing and the other didn't the
fact that Trump is being investigated
for taking at his Direction tons of
documents down to Mar-A-Lago
trying to avoid returning them hiding
them moving them on and on and on the
fact that Trump is accused of that
has no connection whatsoever to the fact
that a few documents were found by
Biden's lawyers they immediately called
the National Archives and said we've got
to get these back to you investigate
Biden for that I'm fine with that as
I've said yesterday but number one it
has no connection to anything that Trump
is accused of doing and number two
look at the differences in how they
handled it as we talked about yesterday
Trump then weighing in on the new
speaker
and Trump I guess tries to make the case
that he deserves the credit for Kevin
McCarthy being speaker game down to
crunch time you know you had 20 people
that were pretty hard line and they
happened to be very good friends of mine
almost all of them I would say all of
them right and uh I would make them
calls I mean because I I didn't like
what was happening John it it was
starting to look a little bit chaotic it
was starting to look a little bit not
good you think right and what happened
is I started calling them and I started
getting people to agree with me and
coming on board right and as you know
Matt Gates is a very good guy and he's
you know he's a strong guy and I called
him big strong guy and he was crying
when I spoke to him at the end I mean it
was just about
over where they were going to leave and
I think that if they left think of it if
they left and you had two and a half
three days in between I don't know that
anything would have ever you might have
ended up with a Democrat to be honest
with you Trump wants us to believe that
were it not for him not only would
McCarthy not be speaker maybe Hakeem
Jeffries would be the speaker I know
that this thing ever would have gotten
done your moderates would have left
other people it would have been a
disaster right and that's when Matt ran
up to the front of the room and he said
I'm changing my vote I'm changing my
vote and he's a great guy yeah now
understand that after Trump issued a not
quite full-throated endorsement of Kevin
McCarthy for house Speaker it took like
12 more rounds of voting before McCarthy
ultimately became the speaker and if we
learned anything from the speaker vote
it's not how much power Trump still has
it's how diminished his power actually
is Trump then of course weighed in on
one of his favorite topics covid and
favorite insofar as he loves to claim he
did great on handling kovid when he was
president
he did not do great doing it and then we
got hit with covet and we had to help
the people with covet you know we would
have done that this country would have I
don't think it would have existed you
know and it was uh we did a great job
with covet I've always felt that you
know people give me a lot of credit on
foreign policy on the economy and things
no they don't but they they don't like
doing it on covet I think I did among
the best jobs on covid because all of a
sudden something came in that nobody had
any idea what it was right we knew it
was killing a lot of people and you know
I closed it to China so now covet was
serious in retrospect remember 15 cases
will soon be zero don't be afraid of it
it's fine now it's oh it was terrible
and I really handled it well a lot of
people didn't want me to do that almost
nobody wanted that was that saved a lot
of lives but you know uh the covet thing
obviously we had to go
guns are blazing with uh with the money
and we had no choice otherwise you know
we had a remember 15 cases will soon be
zero
um what about injecting bleach uh don't
don't don't be afraid of it the
shutdowns are worse than the disease on
and on and on and and the the truth is
the proof is in the outcome world
leaders who handled covet well were all
easily reelected and there is no doubt
that Trump would have been re-elected if
he from the beginning had said this is
really serious
and we're going to do the best job by
being the most aggressive here let's all
wear our masks we're going to offer you
Maga masks that you can buy let's all do
all these things instead they went after
an 80 year old doctor that's that's the
the approach that they ended up taking
okay last thing Trump wants Hannity to
write so that Hannity can get the
Pulitzer and I guess bring back some
Prestige to an award Trump believes is
no longer prestigious yeah
to get the Pulitzer Prize for Russia
Russia Russia reporting and you know the
prize reads to the effect on your great
and Brilliant reporting on Russia well
they got it wrong it was the exact
opposite you should get the Pulitzer
Prize yeah Sean Hannity should start
writing a little bit and get the bullet
hey you guys and Sarah yes it was a
group of people that got it right right
in the beginning and yeah and you know
I'm suing Pulitzer now because I'm
saying you got to take the post I'm
suing vulitzer now you know
um completely deranged and delusional
and I mean listen how about just do the
joy George Santos claimed that you got
the Pulitzer Prize and the Nobel Peace
Prize and whatever else a purple heart
and you lived in the belly of a whale
just claim that you did this stuff but
very very strange
Trump deflated Trump confused Trump
disoriented but as narcissistic as ever
even in his rewriting of History maybe
at some point soon he'll show his face
in one of these interviews that would be
an interesting thing to see but for a
guy who criticized Joe Biden for
campaigning from his basement Trump's
barely left his house since he announced
he was running in 2024 back in November
very strange stuff one of our sponsors
is paired the app for couples every day
paired gives you and your partner
questions quizzes games to have fun to
stay connected to deepen your
conversations and get to know each other
better what's great about it is you
don't even have to be in the same room
especially with the baby right now my
girlfriend and I are quite busy and
paired really helped us to stay
connected you get a daily question to
answer you can't see your partner's
answer until you answer yourself and
their questions about everything
relationship life intimacy other things
and all of the exercises were developed
by academic psychologists and expert
relationship therapists as well
questions like what makes you feel lucky
in your relationship great when you want
to remember and have gratitude a really
great thing what's an activity you could
try together this month actually gets
people thinking about things to do it
can go in really funny directions as
well but it just always feels like time
well spent head over to paired.com
Pacman for a seven day free trial and 25
off a subscription the link is down
below